Boy Scouts are learning about paying
attention to molestation in their troops
they're learning about human resources
that's entrepreneurship no girl no Girl
Scouts is entrepreneurship cuz they give
you all this cute sh and like you want
to buy some Thin Mint and then when
you're like oh sorry I don't have any
cash as you're leaving like whatever you
poor piece of
[Music]
[__] moment of silence oh all right the
Girl Scouts are discontinuing a popular
cookie better not be some what can we
guess can we guess there's not a bit no
jokes here it's going to be why are
theying [__] samosas it better not be
trees better not be Tagalongs and it
better not be tree foils dude that's all
of them tree foils triles hey what's the
lemon one cuz that one can yeah that can
go for yeah the lemon one can [__]
they got some new Girl Scout cookies you
guys ever heard about this one called
thmes
THM what's that that's the that's the
one TR foils what's that th might yeah
nobody knows about it yeah yeah
Scandinavian are they really
discontinuing that one yeah dude dude
it's gone what it's gone nobody's buying
it everyone says it sucks no wait which
they say it sucks and they say it's gay
that's one of the most popular ones wait
wait which one which one the gay part I
can believe somebody said it was gay
that's one of the most popular ones get
so gay now I like that one they said
whoever buys it is gay they're not just
continuing thin no they're not just K
it's you ever heard is literally the
most popular one I love that is it I
thought samosas were samosas samosas
Samos you guys ever heard of of
raspberry rally no so that's the one
that's being discontinued Rasberry rally
the heck heard can you show us I'll show
you what the [__] I thought the girls I
thought the girls got by the way F mins
are bomb when you put them in the
freezer the best no way that's stupid
everyone does that you normie what is
your guys's favorites though the
tagalogs or the SAS I like you got
flamed for no reason I like the den why
do they call it a Tagalog like a
Filipino language Tagalog it's is it
tagalong it's tagal yeah Tagalog right
Tagalog T and there's there's the Samoa
like the island of Samoa like where do
they come up with the name
samoas Samo s s I am a Samoa well
there's an S at so it's plural so it's
SAS okay you guys remember raspberry
rally no that's the point nobody had
this one let me see I probably tastes
like [__] I've never seen that before I
would eat it but no it's never offer
that probably tastes like those little
chocolates that have wine in them oh no
yeah I don't like I feel bad for the old
lady that like loves though I know
there's you know there's a couple 12 hey
I heard about like um the [__] that girl
scouts get to learn and I was like bro I
thought this whole time I wanted to be a
Boy Scout but I think I actually want to
be a girl scout what do they get to
learn
entrepreneurship oh cuz I guess do they
learn entrepreneurship yeah they learn
how to sell [__] bookkeep they learn
they don't learn entrepreneurship they
learn how to be an employee they're
[__] making money for the top no I
thought they learned how to [__] make
uh a balance sheet Boy Scouts no
entrepreneurship what the because in
order in order to rank up you have to
[__] hold leadership positions in
different plac so you have to learn what
it is to be an employee for a certain
amount of months then you have to learn
what it means to be an assistant of your
Patrol then you have to be a patrol
leader then you have to be an assistant
oh and guess what the whole time you
can't lean on the [__] cookies can't
lean on the cookies like the girls Boys
Scouts do kind of sell popcorn so they
kind of dabble in order to econom but
it's not the that just sounds like
you're climbing the corporate ladder
yeah but you hold higher positions Girl
Scouts you only hold employee position
Girl Scouts dude Girl Scouts have it
easy cuz they're leaning on a [__]
successful Pro product so they're like
drug dealers easiest product ever of all
time it's like they're selling crystal
math capitalist baby yeah exactly but
they're like they're selling crystal
meth to people and it's like no [__]
it's going to work but besides selling
cookies what else do they do cuz I
thought that cookies girl SC cookies are
like drugs so really they're entering
the drug trade yeah yeah accounting they
learn accounting they don't do that [__]
their moms do trust me I seen it I've
been [__] doing this [__] every year
all right it's so from the heart that
any Grandma who likes raspberry route is
getting [__] right now they don't give
a [__] honestly Girl Scouts is Cut
Throat anytime there's like like Girl
Scout cookies outside the supermarket
and they come up to you like would you
like to buy some I always fold but then
the other day the Boy Scouts were trying
to sell me some [__] and I was like I'm
not interested you got to buy the
popcorn what's the Boy Scouts highest
selling thing what do they sell
knots they sell selling
jams what is it what do you what did
they sell they sell [__] bondage
ropes bondage ropes they sell bondage
ropes you know you know what Boy Scouts
America really sells they [__] sell
handbooks and uniforms to the boys
that's where they make their money dude
I'm telling you right now it's a pyramid
did you guys know especially like 15 20
years ago the number one selling book
outside of the Bible in the world was
the Boy Scout Handbook because you're
required to buy them required to
purchase it that's a pyramid scam man
yeah which is why entrepreneurship is
actually there W yeah about Girl Scouts
are learning how to sell to the public
they got s skills Scientologist having
to buy elwan hubber books who gives a
[__] boy scouts are learning about
paying attention to molestation in their
troops they're learning about human
resources
that's entrepreneurship no girl no Girl
Scouts is entrepreneurship cuz they give
you all this cute [__] and they're like
you want to buy some Thin Mint and then
when you're like oh sorry I don't have
any cash as you're leaving like whatever
you poor [__] prick piece of
[__] under your under their breath as
you're walking away towards the car yeah
they're like you piece of [__] [__] you
you poor broke [__] you don't
have any money actually [__] you under
their breath though yo you remember when
Girl Scouts were setting up booths right
next to dispensaries and [__] so genius
that's pretty smart damn cookies outside
of dispensaries is that entrepreneurship
the corporate ladder bro they are not
the ladder they are the one step of the
ladder and they stay there
wow that's cuz they tried and true
product you know what I'm talking about
they have the illusion of
Entrepreneurship in order to stay
employees of the company yes well they
get chucked out into the Wilderness bro
they learn how to sell lemonades sell
the peanut butter cookies or D lemonades
I remember it's like our [__] troop
was so successful so amazing selling
[__] girls SC cookies they're like
dude we sold x amount of boxes and what
did I have to do every [__] Saturday
we had to go to the [__] Warehouse
pick up all these box just manual labor
I'm like this is the reward for selling
a lot picking up [__] tons of [__]
boxes out of a truck or a U-Haul and
then taking to the spot and then making
sure that you deliver it to every single
one of your clients that sign up on
these tiny [__] pieces of paper and
then making sure they collect money and
then where does that money go [__]
like 30 cents on the [__] $10 goes
goes back to your Tru goes all the way
30 cents of0 money you make people money
and that's magazine sales magazine sales
you're in fifth grade sixth grade they
teach you how to [__] sell yep you
[__] yourself out to your grandma
chocolate [__] you remember those news
not the the hey Grandpa you need a
Mental Health Magazine he's like what
the [__] do I need that [__] for I'm a
74y old alcoholic and like Grandpa you
need this [__] look six I'm trying to
hit go so I can have some free Subway
sandwiches on
Friday just buy it yeah and they teach
you that [__] and you yourself bu myself
that [__] that [__] newspaper
material of thetic no no that it was
like a um book ERS yeah and then you can
get your [__] Goosebumps book there
you get
Scholastic it's Scholastic the guy
closest to your ear set it I I don't
know what that is that's what it's like
sitting over there and that's
entrepreneurship and then sometimes they
had the Highlights magazine yep
highlights and I'm all like why would
you Disney
Adventures only magazine I ever
subscribed to was Maxim you subscribe to
Maxim let's go you're straight you're
little fashionista dude let's go
straight men this whole time you thought
you were gay I used just open them it's
the illusion we all lost a bet I I bet
that you were
gay I can make you
win for a moment I used to do the the um
you know you you go to the store and you
look at the maximum and you just try to
take as many mental shots as you can yep
yep I did that all the time with like
anime stuff that was in the store that
was sick it's it's it's so good to see
that and then you go oh like you're in
bed you're just like oh what does she
look like again and you're like oh I
forgot what her nipples look like I
wonder if her nipples are big or if
they're small yeah do I remember my dad
would buy all these Men's Health
magazines and they always have like 27
scorching sex tips that's going to spice
your life up and I'd be like 11 trying
to read it like like I understand like
what the [__] they're talking about like
dude I'm going to be so [__] good at
this like I'm going to be so sick at sex
this going to be awesome and I would
just do that so what I was doing was way
more gay than everything actually it was
really really good advice I remember
that stuff too but it would only be like
12 years I don't remember any it would
be like make sure you brush your teeth
right you know what I'm talking about it
was like really basic stuff that made a
lot of sense I remember when it got it
like it got a little less crazy like it
got more crazy than 27 it was like 57
tips it's like Jesus I got to start like
like a test yeah have a light lunch
before so you know Playboy is like fifth
grade gold right oh yeah so my my friend
James his dad would just let him [__]
see the Playboys and we would all go to
his house let him yeah or like force him
I was was like well his dad was do do
you have a door charge or cover fee nah
he's all like my son's straight like he
just [__] doesn't care he should have
charged the door but he probably was in
the Girl Scouts so he didn't know how to
yeah he didn't think about business the
Girl Scouts would have been like you
piece of [__] for your charge with the
door you son of a [__] it [__] like a
son of a [__] why didn't you do it why'
you do it you got to close those deals
you got to
close you're not closing you're [__]
useless those young cool like [__]
you know they're they're party parents
right so then he's like yeah my son's
straight whatever and I was like what
are you tell I was like no but this is
this is the hack the my son straight
he's going
to we thought we outsmarted the parents
cuz I would be like how did you even get
this privilege and he goes I tell him
that I like the Articles and I'm like
what he goes yeah they think I'm reading
the Articles and I'm like no [__] way
so he goes like so when the so when his
dad like out and and then he's like oh
there a new issue out he's like oh it's
oh I love these articles and then so he
goes we're going to go read them and
then [__] off dude he's like reading
gives me a boner bro his parents [__]
knew but it was our kid mind thinking
right that you were smart we outsmarted
them yeah yeah beat these stupid sons of
[__] that's so good [__] '90s
parenting right like they didn't give a
[__] and his mom gave me champagne it
was that kind of household yeah gave you
she'll be hitting a [__] joint and
she's like you want to try this cuz I
kept looking at her [__] drinking uh
champagne and smoking weed so I was like
yeah I drink all the time my my parents
they give me wine and whatever I [__]
[__] it she goes yeah right and then
she poured me a little bit on the cup
and I was like fine I just drank it I
was like this is so gross and I started
puking like crazy that's some '90s [__]
for sure they were Japanese 9s was sick
bring those parents back they were white
uh mom was black black and dad was white
oh damn lucky they weren't Chinese they
would have kicked your Japanese ass
out his dad was so cool cuz he worked um
at Fox Studios so I was like oh when we
go pick him up sometimes we just be like
wow this is [__] you work in the
movie industry all that stuff yeah but
they were just hella hippie out like
they didn't give a [__]
yeah